j'ai trouvé des nouveaux objets étranges
venus du japon vous savez ce pays
totalement normal si vous consommez du
hellez je vais essayer ces objets what
the fuck juste pour vous car vous êtes 9
millions d'abonnés et pour fêter ça
poisson cru tout d'abord un jouet pour
apprendre à manger du poisson avec des
baguettes top de l'éclade super sympa
prêts en francs me semblait que dans le
jouet il y avait la notion de jeu là
c'est le pire cadeau du joyeux noël
tiens un jouet je peux changer familles
nanties dit japon 10 technologies avec
ce petit boîtier qui fonctionne comme
une alarme mais qui balance le message
qu'on veut en fait c'est très pratique
pour se souvenir des trucs un peu comme
un post-it mais en sans fois plus cher
je vais enregistrer un message que vous
m'en voyez tous les jours par mail comme
ça moi je les biens en effet plus de
vidéos
ces transferts et là dessus maintenant
on va le mettre là car ta gueule jeu
antoine daniel je te laisse cet objet
encore un objet pas technologique mais
que les japonais ont rendu technologique
la raquette de ping pong fait le bruit
d'une partie de ping-pong voilà comme ça
mais besoin de table plus besoin de baal
plus besoin d'amis plus besoin d'estimé
de soi
marsh jeu je fais quoi
petite astuce pour vous si un jour de
pluie vous voyez un mec comme ça c'est
que cet homme possède peut-être un
parapluie avec le dessous une jupe d'une
fille reconnaît bien le dire après les
gens font ce qu'ils veulent juste être
loin des écoles tu peux ne pas appeler
la police s'il te plaît trop tard oui il
est juste à côté de moi dans sa culotte
on s'est compliqué de faire l'impasse
sur un moment musical avec un instrument
très noble en hêtre massif à n'ont alors
pas du tout c'est une peluche avec alors
non je ne vais pas jouer de ce truc hein
il me faudrait au moins une percussion
je sais pas aux concerts tous les soirs
chez moi vous doutez bien que personne
ne joue de cet instrument
ok d'après vous quel est cet objet
réponse à boîte à bijoux des ponts sve
une boîte à bonbons réponse c'est un
chat qui veulent t sous et bat c'était
la réponse c est que même le duper et
bah non il trop con alors là on tient un
truc que j'aurais rêvé avoir au lycée
parce que moi en cours je passais mon
temps comme ça mais cet effort constant
de soutenir sa tête comme cela crée des
tensions 1 dans l'avant bras parce que
oui c'est douloureux l'école et cinq
japonais l'ont bien compris le bras
repose-tête ci après comme ça je peux
faire ce que je veux de mes deux mains
comme par exemple ne rien faire elle te
plat comme c'est mignon on arrête un peu
les conneries là et des choses plus
graves dans la vie quand vous regardez
dans smartphone dans ton lit et que tu
as mal le bras bas voilà voilà
alors des choses qui fâchent un petit
peu merci grâce au bras articulé pour
smartphones qui chargent en plus c'est
très bien pensé je peux regarder dans
mon lit une vidéo sur la reproduction
humaine tout en ayant les mains libres à
cette comète une grosse merde ne prenez
pas exemple sur lui au moment beauté du
japon s'avère fois je vous ai demandé de
ne pas faire de screenshots et vous
n'avez pas du tout mais cette fois ci je
vous demande s'il vous plaît ne propagez
pas mon visage je compte sur vous c'est
pour vous je fais ça alors respectez moi
je vais utiliser cet objet de journée
hélas ça n'a pas très envie sur la boîte
bonjour à ce masque de hannibal lecter
sert à se muscler le visage grâce à
trois minutes d'exercice par jour c'est
écrit sur la boîte ça doit raffermir les
muscles du visage
ils ont oublié un petit effet secondaire
ils se situent juste ici avant le masque
d'exercice spatiale après le masque
d'exercice faciale va de captures
d'écran ok je compte sur vous bon cet
objet qui ressemble à une arme de
torture est en fait une arme de torture
pour avoir le nez parfait il suffit de
se lancer comme ça dans les narines la
même
ils voient la l2 porté pendant trois
minutes par jour à 3 minutes comme le
masque d'hannibal lecter comme ça on
peut combiner pour gagner du temps que
je voulais entre eux que non ma vie
c'est ça il est temps de passer à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
divertissant le combat de robots et les
poussent maintenant on a carrément une
télécommande et robotisés waouh
moi on m'a tout seul il tombait tout ce
jamaa
oui pas la caméra pas la caravane arrête
je vais tomber arrêt au à l'amiable
c'est à l'ombre est absolument de pose
de super héros passe à cette poule à
japonais je prends une photo la rotation
de l'engrenage de l'explosion oui quoi
les embauches hors d'âge qui rira 6
c'est à ça que ça sert en paix dans la
salle hubert de fire s'est vu confier
les rendements ne pas quitter la scène a
tout gagné
ceux qui viennent ça a tout gagné
attends attends et au hockey
respect à défaut de faire les plus
impressionnants ces gracieux bébel dans
ces grades et classieux c'est bien au
japon c'est qu'ils ont un temps d'avancé
sur la mode ici par exemple pour être
frais il faut porter quoi une casquette
nul
eux ils ont beaucoup mieux un casque de
samurai bonds flab élégant discret voit
un petit peu avec tous styles de tenues
vous sauver d'une noyade alors je sais
très bien ce que vous allez me dire
ouais mais cyprien caisse de samouraï
mais tape à l'armure c'est nul je suis
bien d'accord avez vous avez
parfaitement raison d admirer cette
magnifique armure de samouraï voilà a
fait un carton extrêmement résistance à
résister aux balles au katana juste
faire attention à la pluie alors je sais
ce que vous allez me dire mais cyprien
si seulement tu étais un petit peu plus
at il dit dans avec un masque d'un
personnage de dragon ball z par exemple
je suis bien d'accord que c'est un
masque de beauté en fait pour la cause
que je ressemble à freezer je suis le
cousin en roumain de freezer me voilà
prêt à affronter le monde - a samurai
prise alors avec le truc comme le bras
ouais je regarde cette vidéo je continue
à voir mon petit 1 ne t'inquiète pas
c'était ma petite vidéo pour fêter les 9
millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne donc un
énorme merci j'espère je suis
extrêmement séduisant et que je vous
plais énormément j'en doute pas une
seule seconde c'est un énorme honneur
voilà d'avoir autant de autant de
personnes qui me suivent sur youtube
pour faire des trucs très très sérieux
comme vous pouvez le remarquer on ne
savait peut-être mais quand on a 10
millions d'abonnés youtube nous envoie
un bouton en diamant même si je crois
que cette bêta les bus verts mais celle
en forme de diamant ou peut-être grâce à
vous je serai la première personne en
france à recevoir ce bouton qui sait
quelqu'un d'autre peut-être je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas si on y arrive ce
serait exceptionnel on va y arriver
encore merci à très vite dans la
prochaine vidéo
je crois que j'ai un post it qui coûte
cher qui veulent y aura plus de place